This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In 1974, the singer Harry Chapin hit number one on the Billboard charts, with a song about loss and love. It told the story of a dad who missed his son's first steps. A child arrived just the other day. He came to the world and the usual way, but there were planes to catch and bills to pay. He learned to walk while I was away and he was talking for a new end and as he grew, he'd say, I'm
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。1974年，歌手哈里·查平凭借一首关于失去与爱的歌登上了公告牌排行榜榜首。这首歌讲述了一位父亲错过了儿子迈出第一步的故事。孩子前几天刚出生。他以寻常的方式来到这个世界，但父亲总有赶不完的飞机和付不完的账单。当父亲不在家时，他学会了走路，并开始牙牙学语，随着他慢慢长大，他会说，我
gonna be. The father misses other milestones. Games of catch get postponed and before he knows it, an entire childhood was his buy as work and other commitments keep the father from spending time with his son. The song Cats in the Cradle was inducted into the Grammy Hall of Fame in 2011. In a few memorable verses, it told the story of a life where your choices come full circle. The enduring popularity of cats in the cradle reflects a sad truth. We often take the most meaningful parts of our lives for granted, only to realize what we have lost after it's too late.
将来要成为……父亲错过了其他的里程碑。接球游戏被推迟了，还没等他意识到，整个童年就已经离他而去，因为工作和其他事务让父亲无法陪伴儿子。歌曲《猫在摇篮里》于2011年入选格莱美名人堂。在几段令人难忘的歌词中，它讲述了一个人生选择最终循环往复的故事。《猫在摇篮里》经久不衰的流行反映了一个悲伤的事实。我们常常认为生活中最有意义的部分是理所当然的，直到为时已晚才意识到我们失去了什么。
Many philosophical and spiritual traditions counsel people to express gratitude for the good things in their lives and to engage fully with the present. So why do so many of us have trouble slowing down and savoring life? This week on Hidden Brain, we begin a two-part series about why it's so hard to stop and notice what is wonderful about our lives and powerful psychological techniques to help us master this art. Life is what happens when you're busy making other plants. It's a quote widely attributed to John Lennon by the origins of this idea predate the Beatles by centuries. At Loyola University Chicago, psychologists Fred
许多哲学和精神传统建议人们对生活中的美好事物表达感激，并充分投入到当下。那么，为什么我们这么多人难以放慢脚步去细细品味生活呢？本周在《Hidden Brain》节目中，我们将开始一个两部分的系列节目，探讨为什么停下来去关注生活中美好的事物如此困难，以及帮助我们掌握这种艺术的强大心理学技巧。生活就是当你忙于制定其他计划时所发生的一切。这句话被广泛归功于约翰·列侬，但这一思想的起源比披头士乐队早了几个世纪。在芝加哥洛约拉大学，心理学家弗雷德·
Bryant studies this universal human conundrum and what we can do about it. Fred Bryant, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar. It's a pleasure to be here. I want to take you back Fred to the early days of your career. You had two small kids, but you were also really consumed with your research and teaching responsibilities. Did you ever feel like these were in conflict with each other? Yes, I did. I remember sitting in a school auditorium with lots of proud parents.
布莱恩特研究了这个普遍的人类难题以及我们能为此做些什么。弗雷德·布莱恩特，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。谢谢你，尚卡尔。很高兴来到这里。弗雷德，我想带你回到你职业生涯的早期。你有两个年幼的孩子，但你也确实被研究和教学职责所消耗。你是否曾觉得这些与你的家庭生活存在冲突？是的，我有过。我记得坐在学校礼堂里，周围有很多自豪的父母。
Seeing my daughter come on stage, his ex was a flute player. And the lights went down, the music began. It was fun to watch her. But I began to look at my watch, think about how many more songs would be played and how much more time. And thinking about the section that I might work on when I got back to my manuscripts. So I would not be fully present and I found it a sense of frustration because I could not be in two places at once. I understand your wife sometimes called you the ghost in the house? Yes. That was her term for me. The ghost in the house, I'd be like a ship passing in the night,
看着我的女儿上台，她当时是长笛演奏者。灯光暗了下来，音乐开始了。看着她表演很有趣。但我开始看我的手表，思考还会演奏多少首曲子，还需要多少时间。并想着当我回到手稿时可能会处理的部分。所以我无法完全沉浸在当下，我感到一种挫败感，因为我无法同时身处两地。我听说你妻子有时称你为“家里的幽灵”？是的。那是她对我的称呼。家里的幽灵，我就像黑夜中擦肩而过的船，
going down to the basement where my work would take place. I could be relatively isolated from noise and distraction. It wasn't a pleasant thought to realize that was her term for me. I wanted to be present in the house, but be more than a ghost. And yet I felt driven to be productive, to take advantage of opportunities whenever they arose. And I was multitasking constantly, working on multiple projects. And yet there was guilt.
下到地下室去工作。我可以相对与噪音和干扰隔绝。意识到那是她对我的称呼，这并不是一个愉快的想法。我想在家里陪伴家人，但不仅仅是一个幽灵。然而，我感到有一种动力去追求效率，利用每一个出现的机遇。我一直在进行多任务处理，同时进行多个项目。然而，我感到内疚。
And when I would be working on my work, I would often be thinking of what I might be doing with my daughters and with my wife. So eventually your daughters grew up and a few years ago your elder daughter got married. Tell me how you and your wife planned the wedding and what the wedding day was like. We enjoyed the time that we set aside to do that. So many loose ends that had to be taken care of. So many preparations, the catering, the flowers, the
当我工作时，我经常会想我本可以和女儿们以及妻子一起做什么。所以最终你的女儿们长大了，几年前你的大女儿结婚了。告诉我你和妻子是如何筹划婚礼的，婚礼当天是什么样的。我们很享受我们留出来做这件事的时间。有太多琐事需要处理。太多的准备工作，餐饮，鲜花，
music, DJ, the cast list, all of the planning for the venue, visiting different venues. And we thought, well, once this event arrives, the glorious wedding day, then we will be able to let go and just enjoy this. And I remember walking into the place, thinking this was gonna be this celebration and the time to relax and enjoy, but we had too many other loose ends, things that weren't where we thought they would be. The DJ was running late.
音乐，DJ，宾客名单，所有关于场地的规划，参观不同的场地。我们想，好吧，一旦这个活动到来，那辉煌的婚礼当天，我们就能放下一切，尽情享受。我记得走进那个地方，心想这将是一场庆典，是放松和享受的时刻，但我们还有太多未完成的琐事，事情并没有像我们预想的那样就位。DJ迟到了。
The food wasn't where we wanted it. There were too many ongoing dynamic parts. We found we were just waiting for the next problem to arise. And so we realized we could not let go. We could not really immerse ourselves in the moment and ended up being very frustrating for us. I'd like to ask you about one other personal story. I understand that you're a committed mountain climber who often goes on climbing expeditions with friends. Are
食物没有达到我们想要的效果。有太多持续变化的动态部分。我们发现我们只是在等待下一个问题的出现。所以我们意识到我们无法放下。我们无法真正沉浸在当下，最终这对我们来说非常令人沮丧。我想问你另一个个人故事。我听说你是一位坚定的登山者，经常和朋友一起去登山探险。你
you more laid back when it comes to these recreation loudings? Are you still the planner? Always, once and always, the planner. My friends are more in the moment and they let me plan it because I look forward to imagining how it could be and trying to optimize the moment. Everything has to be planned down to the minute if we're going to, we would typically try to climb five or six of these 14,000 foot peaks in a single trip. We might have 10 days, might have a week. How to do that? And what order to do these things? I have a vast library of guidebooks and resources, maps, things that allow me to figure out what we're going to confront if the weather gets bad. Or if we lose something, or supplies run out, all of the equipment we'd need,
在这些休闲活动中会更放松吗？你还是那个规划者吗？永远，过去是，现在也是，规划者。我的朋友们更注重当下，他们让我来规划，因为我期待着想象它会是什么样子，并试图优化这一刻。如果我们打算去的话，一切都必须精确到分钟，我们通常会尝试在一次旅行中攀登五到六座14000英尺的高峰。我们可能有10天，可能有一周。怎么做到这一点？以什么顺序做这些事？我拥有大量的指南书和资源、地图，这些东西让我能够弄清楚如果天气变坏我们会面临什么。或者如果我们丢失了什么，或者补给用完了，我们需要的所有装备，
not only that, how we'd spend the mornings, the afternoons, the evenings, coordinating the flights, the hotel reservations, the rental car, it fell upon me to take that role and that responsibility. I'm wondering during these trips, was there ever a moment that you can recall when maybe you'd climb to the top of one of these peaks and it had been a hard and exhausting climb? And you didn't give yourself the time to actually enjoy what this achievement felt like. Yes, I feel like the school principal telling them to come in from the playground. It's time to get back to the hard work.
不仅如此，我们如何度过早晨、下午、晚上，协调航班、酒店预订、租车，这些角色和责任都落在了我身上。我想知道在这些旅行中，你是否能回忆起某个时刻，也许你爬到了其中一座山峰的顶端，那是一次艰难而令人筋疲力尽的攀登？而你却没有给自己时间去真正享受这种成就感。是的，我觉得自己就像学校校长，催促他们从操场回来。是时候回到艰苦的工作中了。
And I knew how much time we could afford to spend if we wanted to stay on schedule. They would want a linger, perhaps spend an hour and a half, two hours on the summit. I knew that that would not allow us enough time to get back down. The other problem was that the weather is the main danger and the main concern. Up that high, the higher up you are, the more rapidly the weather changes. I would always be worried about that. They call me the worry-wort because I did not want us to turn into human lightning rods. So I didn't really allow much time for that spontaneity to happen. My friends resented it, I think. They felt they should be allowed to be spontaneous.
我知道如果我们想按计划进行，我们能负担得起多少时间。他们会想逗留，也许在山顶待一个半小时、两个小时。我知道那将使我们没有足够的时间下山。另一个问题是天气是主要的危险和主要的担忧。在高处，你越高，天气变化越快。我总是为此担心。他们叫我“忧虑虫”，因为我不想让我们变成人体避雷针。所以我并没有真正留出太多时间让那种自发性发生。我想我的朋友们对此感到不满。他们觉得他们应该被允许自发行动。
Fred, you say your friends resented your efforts to keep them on schedule, but it occurs to me that you yourself missed out on some sublime moments on the mountain top. I'm certain that's the case. I don't think I'd stopped long enough to realize that fact. In a sense, I missed the opportunity to smell the roses when they were there. I think I was driven more by the intenery than I drove the intenery. our tenorory. All of us need to get things done and to stay on track. The more driven we are, the more we can be consumed by deadlines and goals. These can come to dominate our existence. When we come back, why the good things in our lives and the bad things in our lives operate
弗雷德，你说你的朋友们对你让他们按计划进行的努力感到不满，但我想你自己在山顶上也错过了一些绝妙的时刻。我肯定情况确实如此。我不认为我停下来足够长的时间来意识到这个事实。在某种意义上，当玫瑰在那里时，我错过了闻玫瑰的机会。我想我更多是被行程所驱动，而不是我驱动了行程。我们所有人都需要完成任务并保持在轨道上。我们越有动力，就越容易被截止日期和目标所消耗。这些可能会主宰我们的存在。当我们回来时，为什么我们生活中的好事和坏事会以
by different rules and the great mistake we make in dealing with them. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Most of us go through life, focused on the things that make us unhappy. We spend time thinking about relationships that are not going well. We stay up at night worrying about setbacks at school and at work. When we are sick, our minds are consumed with our own pain and discomfort. At Loyola University Chicago, psychologists Fred Bryant has explored a provocative question. If all of us say we want to be happy, why do we focus
不同的规则运作，以及我们在处理它们时所犯的巨大错误。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们大多数人过着生活，专注于那些让我们不快乐的事情。我们花时间思考那些进展不顺利的关系。我们彻夜难眠，担心学校和工作中的挫折。当我们生病时，我们的思想被自己的痛苦和不适所占据。在芝加哥洛约拉大学，心理学家弗雷德·布莱恩特探索了一个挑衅性的问题。如果我们所有人都说我们想快乐，为什么我们专注于
so much time and energy on the things that make us unhappy? Fred, you've explored the difference between the way we attend to our positive and our negative feelings. Describe what we do. Well, we tend to spend more time counting our troubles than our blessings. It's almost an inevitable result of evolution, the negative aspects, the threats in the environment, in the world around us are dangerous, and they can take our lives if we're not cautious and don't avoid them. Whereas the pleasures are not going to take our lives if we don't attend to them. And the idea really is that the troubles are unavoidable, and they actually kick our
如此多的时间和精力在那些让我们不快乐的事情上？弗雷德，你探索了我们关注积极感受和消极感受方式之间的差异。描述一下我们是怎么做的。嗯，我们往往花更多的时间数落我们的麻烦，而不是我们的福气。这几乎是进化的必然结果，消极的方面，环境中的威胁，我们周围世界中的威胁是危险的，如果我们不谨慎且不避免它们，它们可能会夺走我们的生命。而如果我们不关注快乐，它们并不会夺走我们的生命。这个想法实际上是，麻烦是不可避免的，它们实际上会踢开我们的
door in and come and find us, and we're forced then to deal with them, to handle them, whereas the pleasures and the joys, they don't hunt us down and force us to enjoy them. They wait, and they sometimes hide. They require us to go hunting for them, to find them and then spend time with them. This is such an interesting and profound idea, Fred, the idea that sorrows hunt for us, but we have to hunt for joys that they are not equally found in the wild, so to say. Yes, it's just that negative information is processed more rapidly. We tend to remember
门进来找到我们，我们被迫去处理它们，去应对它们，而快乐和喜悦，它们不会追捕我们并强迫我们去享受它们。它们在等待，有时它们会躲藏起来。它们需要我们去寻找它们，找到它们，然后花时间与它们相处。这是一个如此有趣且深刻的想法，弗雷德，悲伤追捕我们，但我们必须追捕快乐，它们在野外并不是同样容易被发现的。是的，只是消极信息被处理得更快。我们倾向于记住
it, retrieve it more readily, we're more influenced by it, we attend to it more. But the positive side is really underestimated. For so many years, the focus in psychology has been on the negative, so that the problem has been relative ignorance with respect to the positive side and managing positive feelings in our lives, taking a kind of active responsibility for them, prioritizing them, structuring time, allowing for that. It's too easy to let the negative swamp our attention and drive our agenda. You know, it's interesting both when it comes to ourselves as well as to our loved ones. We often coach ourselves and our loved ones on how to deal with
它，更容易检索它，我们受它的影响更大，我们更关注它。但积极的一面确实被低估了。多年来，心理学的重点一直放在消极方面，所以问题在于对积极方面以及管理我们生活中的积极感受、对它们承担某种积极责任、优先考虑它们、构建时间、允许这种情况发生的相对无知。让消极情绪淹没我们的注意力并驱动我们的议程太容易了。你知道，无论是对自己还是对我们所爱的人，这都很有趣。我们经常指导自己和我们所爱的人如何处理
adversity. So, you know, parents might teach their children how to ride a bike and you're saying, you know, here's what you do and here's how you keep from falling. And, you know, if you fall, here's how you can brace your fall. And, you know, here's what you, and you're teaching your child to cope with bad things that could happen. And, of course, that's a good thing to do. But we assume that in some ways there is no coaching or teaching required when it's a good thing, no parent ever sits down, a child and says, let me teach you how to eat ice cream and to enjoy ice cream. It almost seems absurd to say that.
逆境。所以，你知道，父母可能会教他们的孩子如何骑自行车，你会说，你知道，这是你该做的，这是你如何防止摔倒的方法。而且，你知道，如果你摔倒了，这是你可以支撑摔倒的方法。而且，你知道，这是你该做的，你在教你的孩子应对可能发生的坏事。当然，这是一件好事。但我们假设在某种程度上，当它是好事时，不需要任何指导或教学，没有父母会坐下来，对孩子说，让我教你如何吃冰淇淋并享受冰淇淋。说这话似乎很荒谬。
But when we spend so much time coaching ourselves and other people to cope with adversity. Yes. We all catch ourselves in that conundrum. You want to help your children handle the struggles of life to be able to rise above adversity. But you naturally assume somehow that the joys will take care of themselves. That's what struck me initially in my work was that we spent so little time helping people learn how to manage that side of life. It was just taken for granted that the absence of pain and suffering would somehow guarantee the finding of joy. And that is just not the case. One of the great insights that my most influential mentor, Joseph Virov, taught me and was just because you're not down, doesn't mean you're up.
但当我们花这么多时间指导自己和他人应对逆境时。是的。我们都发现自己陷入了那个难题。你想帮助你的孩子处理生活的挣扎，能够超越逆境。但你自然而然地假设某种程度上快乐会照顾好自己。这正是我在工作中最初打动我的地方，我们花在帮助人们学习如何管理生活那一方面的时间太少了。人们只是理所当然地认为，没有痛苦和苦难在某种程度上就能保证找到快乐。而事实并非如此。我最有影响力的导师约瑟夫·维罗夫教给我的伟大见解之一就是，仅仅因为你没有处于低谷，并不意味着你处于巅峰。
That was profound. I always had assumed, as most psychologists and earlier times, that if people were not pressed by adversity, we're not struggling suffering, that somehow then the natural state, the default status, would be happiness. The default is the absence of suffering. It's not happiness. Happiness is really something you have to be on the lookout for. Is there any evidence that teaching ourselves or teaching others to develop the capacity
那很深刻。我一直假设，像大多数心理学家和早期时代一样，如果人们没有受到逆境的压力，没有在挣扎受苦，那么某种程度上自然状态，默认状态，就是快乐。默认状态是没有痛苦。它不是快乐。快乐真的是你需要去寻找的东西。有没有证据表明教导我们自己或教导他人发展应对逆境的能力
to cope with adversity also somehow transmutes itself into a capacity to enjoy life? Very little evidence for that. The two are really separate sets of skills, the capacity to cope and the capacity to find the joy. Many of the things that we would do to help us cope with misfortune and accident and adversity involve muting, dampening, cutting short the emotional experience. We want the pain to go away.
也某种程度上转化为享受生活的能力？几乎没有证据支持这一点。这两者实际上是两套独立的技能，应对的能力和寻找快乐的能力。我们为了帮助自己应对不幸、事故和逆境而做的许多事情都涉及静音、减弱、缩短情感体验。我们希望痛苦消失。
We want the fear to dissipate. We want the fear to dissipate. We want the anxiety, the worry to vanish. We want to get beyond these things and pass them. We oftentimes tell ourselves not to think about it, not to dwell on it, that this will pass. If you do those kinds of coping strategies when a good thing happens. Tell yourself, this is not that good. Try not to think about it. Just figure that we'll be through it soon. It will be gone. Think of other things.
我们希望恐惧消散。我们希望恐惧消散。我们希望焦虑、担忧消失。我们希望超越这些事情并度过它们。我们经常告诉自己不要去想它，不要纠结于它，这会过去的。如果你在好事发生时采取那种应对策略。告诉自己，这没那么好。尽量不要去想它。只是认为我们很快就会度过它。它会消失的。想别的事情。
Try not to dwell on it. Well, what does that do to the joy? I mean, it more or less kills it. So if that's habitual, if that's our dominant approach, mentally and behaviorally, to bad things when they happen. Be very easy for us to apply those same rules to positive experiences and we're out of luck. We've actually undermined them. So you've devoted decades to studying the phenomenon of savoring, and I think we all understand
尽量不要纠结于它。嗯，这对快乐有什么影响？我的意思是，它或多或少杀死了它。所以如果那是习惯性的，如果那是我们面对坏事发生时的主要心理和行为方式。我们很容易将同样的规则应用于积极的体验，而我们运气不佳。我们实际上破坏了它们。所以你花了数十年时间研究品味现象，我想我们都理解
the term, but you say it involves an element of something that psychologists call meta-cognition. Explain what this means for it. As meta-cognition is thinking about our own mental states, thinking about our own feelings. Oh, this feels good. Or I'm liking this. I haven't felt this way in a while, you might say. It also involves an ability to be aware of one's attentional focus, what it is that one's looking at. Just sitting, for example, in a beautiful garden or strolling through
这个术语，但你说它涉及心理学家所称的元认知的一个要素。弗雷德，解释一下这意味着什么。元认知是思考我们自己的心理状态，思考我们自己的感受。哦，这感觉很好。或者我喜欢这个。你可能会说，我有一段时间没有这种感觉了。它还涉及一种意识到一个人的注意力焦点、一个人正在看什么的能力。例如，只是坐在一个美丽的花园里或漫步
and looking for what comes our way. You'd be aware of every thought, every step. If you're looking at a beautiful flower, what kinds of feelings come to mind. You might smell the flower, what memories come to mind in the aroma. It involves a kind of mindful awareness of one's own positive experiences. And that is the essence of savoring. It is really the capacity to notice and to attend to and to appreciate a positive experience, whether it's coming from outside us or within us. So in previous episodes of Hidden Brain, we've talked about another important psychological concept,
并寻找出现在我们面前的东西。你会意识到每一个想法，每一步。如果你正在看一朵美丽的花，脑海中会浮现出什么样的感觉。你可能会闻到花香，香气中会浮现出什么样的记忆。它涉及一种对自己积极体验的正念觉知。这就是品味的本质。它确实是注意到、关注并欣赏积极体验的能力，无论是来自我们外部还是内部。所以在之前的《Hidden Brain》剧集中，我们谈到了另一个重要的心理学概念，
the hedonic treadmill, something brings us joy and a new car, a new house, a new city. But over time, we get used to the thing that gave us joy and we might even, a new house, a new city, but over time we get used to the thing that gave us joy and we might even get bored with it. Researchers have shown that the hedonic treadmill shows up even as people are eating dessert in the course of a single meal. Can you explain what they found and how savoring can affect this process? Yes, that's a universal phenomenon that's underappreciated.
享乐适应，某样东西给我们带来快乐，一辆新车，一所新房子，一个新城市。但随着时间的推移，我们习惯了给我们带来快乐的东西，我们甚至可能，一所新房子，一个新城市，但随着时间的推移，我们习惯了给我们带来快乐的东西，我们甚至可能对它感到厌倦。研究人员已经表明，即使人们在吃一顿饭的过程中吃甜点，享乐适应也会出现。你能解释一下他们发现了什么以及品味如何影响这个过程吗？是的，这是一个被低估的普遍现象。
One way to think of it is the fact that the human system exquisite as it is in sensation, perception. It has its limits over time and that what initially strikes us as powerfully pleasant or powerfully unpleasant will over time fade, it will drain away, and it has adaptive value, certainly helpful to us to be able to handle unpleasant feelings, pain.
思考它的一种方式是，人类系统在感觉、知觉方面是极其精致的。它随着时间的推移有其局限性，最初让我们感到强烈愉悦或强烈不愉悦的东西会随着时间的推移而消退，它会流失，并且它具有适应性价值，当然，能够处理不愉快的感受、痛苦对我们是有帮助的。
For example, you can get used to pain if it becomes chronic, you kind of live with it and don't think about it. And yet it has its drawbacks, this hedonic system, in the fact that we grow used to and accustomed to positive things. And it's inevitable from a physiological point of view that the system seems to be less sensitive over time to the pleasurable stimuli that at first was exquisite. Classic case in point, you go into a bakery and you are bombarded with aromas,
例如，如果痛苦变成慢性的，你可以习惯它，你某种程度上与它共存而不去想它。然而，这个享乐系统有其缺点，即我们习惯并适应了积极的事物。从生理学的角度来看，系统似乎随着时间的推移对起初极其美妙的愉悦刺激变得不那么敏感，这是不可避免的。经典的例子，你走进一家面包店，你被香气轰炸，
the smell of freshly baked bread, chocolate pastries, all of the smell is divine. It's just overwhelming. Within a few minutes, we might not even realize it. Someone else will come in the door a few minutes later and they'll say, the aroma, and you'll think, what aroma? The aroma is, oh, it's right. You realize that it would take you leaving, walking around the block, clearing the nasal passage, come back in. Hey, there's the aroma again. Where did it go? It was there all the time, but we get used to it. The trouble is we get used to anything when we're surrounded by it. We only really know what we've got when it's gone.
刚出炉的面包味，巧克力糕点，所有的气味都是神圣的。这简直是压倒性的。几分钟内，我们甚至可能都没有意识到。几分钟后，另一个人会进门，他们会说，这香气，而你会想，什么香气？香气是，哦，对了。你意识到你需要离开，绕着街区走一圈，清理鼻腔，再回来。嘿，香气又回来了。它去哪儿了？它一直都在那里，但我们习惯了它。问题是我们被它包围时就习惯了任何东西。我们只有在它消失时才真正知道我们拥有什么。
So it takes the losing of the thing to fully appreciate what having it is about. And the same thing holds true from a psychological point of view, with all of the good things in our lives. Fred, have people figured out how to halt, or at least, slow down the hedonic treadmill? Yes, I mean, we've learned over time, but the idea of, say, wholping down a pizza that is going to taste better if we can get more of it rapidly. That's counterproductive. If we get a windfall of gifts all at once, don't owe them all immediately. Spread them over time, the research show. Far better for us to slow
所以需要失去某样东西才能充分欣赏拥有它意味着什么。从心理学的角度来看，我们生活中所有美好的事物也是如此。弗雷德，人们是否找到了停止或至少减缓享乐适应的方法？是的，我的意思是，我们随着时间的推移学到了，但比如狼吞虎咽地吃披萨，如果我们能快速吃更多，它会更好吃。那是适得其反的。如果我们一次性得到一堆礼物，不要立刻全部拥有它们。研究表明，将它们分散在一段时间内。我们最好放慢
down and to stretch the time and the experience out. That is the number one savering strategy people adopt when instructed to try to enjoy and experience the most they possibly can. And I've done this work across culture. This is a universal strategy people adopt is to slow down. They'll spend some time just looking at the bite of chocolate, A universal strategy people adopt is to slow down.
速度，拉长时间和体验。这是人们在被指示尝试尽可能多地享受和体验时采用的第一大品味策略。我在不同文化中做过这项工作。这是一个普遍的策略，人们采用的是放慢速度。他们会花一些时间只是看着那块巧克力，这是一个普遍的策略，人们采用的是放慢速度。
They'll spend some time just looking at the bite of chocolate, let's say, or the strawberry. They'll spend time sniffing it, setting it down, maybe licking it, but they're not going to consume it all rapidly, actually swishing the food around on the palate, closing the eyes to try to intensify the sensations, the taste on the tongue. And that's a very mindful, deliberate process aimed at maintaining the positive experience and prolonging it. Now, you could say if you want more intensity, you would do it as a dog might eat a piece of steak on a plate on the floor, and it's gone before you can sit down. They go for oomph and intensity, whereas human beings say, okay, that would work, but it'd be over, and then where would I be? If you want to smell the roses, you have to slow down, or if you're going to drive by and roll the windows down and
他们会花一些时间闻它，放下它，也许舔它，但他们不会快速消耗它，实际上是在味蕾上搅动食物，闭上眼睛尝试加强感觉，舌头上的味道。这是一个非常正念、深思熟虑的过程，旨在维持积极体验并延长它。现在，你可以说如果你想要更多的强度，你会像狗在地上盘子里吃牛排一样做，在你坐下之前它就没了。它们追求冲击力和强度，而人类说，好吧，那会奏效，但它会结束，然后我会在哪里？如果你想闻玫瑰，你必须放慢速度，或者如果你打算开车经过并摇下车窗，
try to smell the roses, that's not going to work. So speed and impatience is really the enemy of enjoyment. The lingering is the secret. So you've conducted a number of studies looking at the practical effects of engaging and savoring. One of these experiments examined whether savoring makes us happier in our day-to-day lives. Can you describe the study for us, please? Well, we've done several of such studies to go after research on how people saver on their own when told to go forth and saver. So we had technology that allowed
尝试闻玫瑰，那是不行的。所以速度和不耐烦确实是享受的敌人。留恋是秘诀。所以你进行了许多研究，观察参与和品味实际效果。其中一个实验检查了品味是否让我们在日常生活中更快乐。你能为我们描述一下这项研究吗？嗯，我们做了几项这样的研究，去追踪人们在被告知去品味时如何自己品味的研究。所以我们有技术允许
us to contact people randomly between eight in the morning, eight at night on their device, their phone, they could write down what they were doing, what they were feeling. And then answer questions about whether they had just been savoring or not, which kinds of savoring were they engaging in, and how their feelings were. So we followed people a large sample once a day for 30 days, randomly beeping them and keeping track of their data. What we found was, as we'd expected,
我们在早上八点到晚上八点之间随机联系人们，在他们的设备上，他们的手机上，他们可以写下他们在做什么，他们在感受什么。然后回答关于他们是否刚刚在品味的问题，他们参与了哪种品味，以及他们的感受如何。所以我们追踪了一个大样本，每天一次，持续30天，随机发出蜂鸣声并记录他们的数据。我们发现的是，正如我们所预期的，
when people engaged in savoring in response to a positive event that resulted in significantly stronger positive emotions, immediately afterwards, and then throughout the day, we found that these savoring experiences seemed to magnify and grow over time, and that they, at the end of the month, people's trajectory was uplifted. The more savoring they'd engaged in, in the moment, in real life circumstances, the more joy they were feeling, the more positive emotion they were feeling. We also found that savoring had its strongest effects when people had fewer positive events. It was a bit counterintuitive. In
当人们在回应积极事件时参与品味，这导致了随后以及全天显著更强的积极情绪，我们发现这些品味体验似乎随着时间的推移而放大和增长，并且在月底，人们的轨迹得到了提升。他们在当下、在现实生活环境中参与的品味越多，他们感受到的快乐就越多，他们感受到的积极情绪就越多。我们还发现，当人们有较少的积极事件时，品味的效果最强。这有点违反直觉。换句话说，
other words, that savoring matters most in squeezing the joy from positive moments when you have fewer positive moments to work with. So it's a really important thing to keep in mind. There are many people's circumstances that don't allow them the luxury, the time to save or the opportunities. That doesn't mean that they can't get full joy from that. It means that that's where savoring matters most.
当你的积极时刻较少时，品味在从积极时刻中挤出快乐方面最重要。所以记住这一点非常重要。许多人的环境不允许他们有奢侈的时间去品味或机会。这并不意味着他们不能从中获得充分的快乐。这意味着那是品味最重要的地方。
You've also found that savoring can help with symptoms related to depression or with people suffering from poor health. Walk me through these findings, right? Yes. With respect to depression, the tendency to experience negative emotion, negative affectivity actually dampens the ability to savor the moment. It really puts a damper on the capacity to find joy in the moment,
你还发现品味可以帮助缓解与抑郁相关的症状或帮助健康状况不佳的人。带我了解一下这些发现，好吗？是的。关于抑郁症，体验消极情绪的倾向，消极情感实际上减弱了品味当下的能力。它确实对在当下找到快乐的能力造成了打击，
and that tends to increase the intensity depression over time. The one strategy to battle depression is to teach people to find more joy in the moment, not as easy as it sounds, but it's really one of the goals of cognitive behavioral therapy. The people are actually developing savoring interventions now and working with depressed clients, and it seems to reduce the symptomology. With respect to ill health, we're finding that in chronic disease, life-threatening illnesses, the capacity to savor protect one from depression, the better and stronger one's skills are in savoring. The less likely one is to get depressed over time and the lower the levels of depression and dealing with chronic life-threatening illness.
这往往会随着时间的推移增加抑郁的强度。对抗抑郁的一种策略是教人们在当下找到更多的快乐，这并不像听起来那么容易，但这确实是认知行为疗法的目标之一。人们现在实际上正在开发品味干预措施，并与抑郁症客户合作，这似乎减少了症状学。关于健康状况不佳，我们发现，在慢性病、危及生命的疾病中，品味的能力保护一个人免受抑郁，一个人在品味方面的技能越好、越强。随着时间的推移，一个人患抑郁症的可能性就越小，在处理慢性危及生命的疾病时，抑郁水平也越低。
So, despite these many benefits of savoring, we often fail to savor the good things in life, and I'd like to explore some of the reasons for this. The first, as you've indicated, is that we're simply too rushed, in some ways, as you were when your children were growing up. I mean, that seems to be one of the principal drivers that keeps us from savoring the good things in our lives. Yes, not only this feeling of being rushed in the time is short, but also the tendency to compare our experience to what we thought it would be, or what we hoped it would be, or what we think it should have been. We also compare many times what we're experiencing to what others in the same situation seem to be feeling.
所以，尽管品味有这么多好处，我们经常无法品味生活中的美好事物，我想探讨一下这背后的一些原因。第一个，正如你所指出的，是我们太匆忙了，在某种程度上，就像你孩子长大时那样。我的意思是，这似乎是阻止我们品味生活中美好事物的核心驱动力之一。是的，不仅是这种时间紧迫的匆忙感，还有将我们的体验与我们认为它会是什么样子，或者我们希望它是什么样子，或者我们认为它本应该是什么样子进行比较的倾向。我们还经常将我们正在经历的事情与同一情况下的其他人似乎感受到的事情进行比较。
And that's short circuits, Many of the positive feelings, because we're more interested in analyzing and comparing how we're actually feeling relative to some standard. And that's hardly being in the moment. That's not being here. That's being somewhere else. And hard to be here if you're there. I understand that your brother, George, had an interesting relationship with Christmas each year. But some of his strategy didn't quite work when it came to maximizing his own savoring. Tell me that story, Fred. Yes, he always relished Christmas.
这会短路许多积极的感受，因为我们更感兴趣的是分析和比较我们相对于某种标准实际感受如何。这根本不是在当下。那不是在这里。那是在别处。如果你在那里，很难在这里。我听说你的兄弟乔治每年与圣诞节有一种有趣的关系。但他的一些策略在最大化他自己的品味方面并不完全奏效。告诉我们那个故事，弗雷德。是的，他总是很享受圣诞节。
Before it occurred, he would start a month or two ahead building it up. He would think it would be the best Christmas we've ever had in all our lives. And I thought the one before was pretty good. Oh, no, this is going to be far better than anything we could ever imagine. And I said, really, this sounds great. What are some of the things you think will happen? So we're going to get the biggest best gifts ever. The meal is going to be incredible.
在它发生之前，他会提前一两个月开始酝酿。他会认为这将是我们一生中最好的圣诞节。而我认为之前那个相当不错。哦，不，这将远比我们能想象的任何事情都要好得多。我说，真的，这听起来很棒。你认为会发生的一些事情是什么？所以我们将得到有史以来最大最好的礼物。这顿饭将是不可思议的。
There'll be snow. It's going to be magical. Can't wait. And then the night before, there was this huge excitement. But then, Christmas morning would come, and we'd rush into the living room to see all this array of gifts, and they never lived up to what he had imagined they'd be. But there was always next Christmas, so he was very good at building up the anticipation
会有雪。这将是神奇的。等不及了。然后前一天晚上，有这种巨大的兴奋。但随后，圣诞节早晨到来了，我们冲进客厅看到所有这些礼物，它们从来没有达到他想象中的样子。但总有下一个圣诞节，所以他非常擅长建立期待
and enjoying it beforehand, but in the moment it inevitably fell far short of what he had hoped for, and he would be grumpy, he would be disappointed and have to leave the room. So, some of this is about the road of expectations. The higher our expectations, the harder it becomes to save or what it is that we have, to enjoy what it is that we have, because the contrast is a downward contrast. But it's also an example of perhaps killjoy thinking. You know, something wonderful is happening, you're getting something great. But rather than focusing on what's great, your mind is occupied by the ways it falls short.
并提前享受它，但在当下，它不可避免地远低于他所希望的，他会变得脾气暴躁，他会感到失望，不得不离开房间。所以，其中一些是关于期望的道路。我们的期望越高，就越难品味我们所拥有的，去享受我们所拥有的，因为对比是向下的对比。但这也许也是扫兴思维的一个例子。你知道，美妙的事情正在发生，你正在得到伟大的东西。但与其专注于伟大的东西，你的思想被它不足的方式所占据。
Yes, you're thinking to yourself, this should have happened sooner, it could have been better in these ways, or you're thinking, I should be doing something else. You know, I've got other things to do, or I don't deserve this. So the Killjoy thoughts really short circuit the enjoyment of the moment, and they can become an automatic script that we play in our heads in response to positive events. I want to play your clip of music, Fred, that was part of a study conducted by the psychologist Jonathan Schuhler and his colleagues. Here's a clip from a very
是的，你对自己想，这本应该早点发生，它本可以在这些方面更好，或者你在想，我本应该做别的事情。你知道，我有别的事情要做，或者我不配得到这个。所以扫兴的想法确实短路了对当下的享受，它们可以成为我们在回应积极事件时在脑海中播放的自动脚本。弗雷德，我想播放一段音乐片段，这是心理学家乔纳森·舒勒及其同事进行的一项研究的一部分。这是一个非常
famous piece of music. So Jonathan Schuhler played this work right of spring written by the composer Igor Stravinsky for volunteers and he had different groups listen to the music differently. Explain what he did and what he found for it. He asked one group simply to listen to the passage, the musical passage. And the second group was asked to reflect upon how they felt while they were listening to this passage. They were to turn a dial to the right if their feelings
著名的音乐片段。所以乔纳森·舒勒为志愿者播放了作曲家伊戈尔·斯特拉文斯基创作的这部《春之祭》，他让不同的群体以不同的方式聆听音乐。解释一下他做了什么以及他发现了什么。他要求一组人只是聆听这段音乐，这段音乐片段。第二组人被要求反思他们在聆听这段片段时感受如何。如果他们的感受
became increasingly positive, or they were to turn the dial back if the feelings were decreasing. And during this time people were instructed to really keep track of how they were feeling, to evaluate their feelings. Now he found that the group that listened to the passage, while evaluating their feelings, that group ended up at a lower level of enjoyment than a group that simply was asked how they felt after listening to the song with no self-evaluation. So the very act of continually and real-time monitoring the positive feelings ended up undermining the final level of enjoyment.
变得越来越积极，他们就转动拨盘向右，或者如果感受在减少，他们就转回拨盘。在这段时间里，人们被指示真正追踪他们的感受，评估他们的感受。现在他发现，在评估感受的同时聆听片段的那一组，最终的享受水平低于仅仅被要求在听完歌后感受如何而没有自我评估的那一组。所以，持续和实时监控积极感受的行为最终破坏了最终的享受水平。
It's almost as if you pay a price for too much self-reflection. I'm wondering, Fred, if this is at odds with what you told me earlier, when we talked about the role of Medi-Cognition, and that savoring is not just simply enjoying something, but being aware that you're enjoying something, taking note of it, is that idea at odds with the idea in this study, which is that the more you pay attention to the things that you are enjoying, the less you enjoy it? Very good, Sean Carr. That is one of the paradoxes of savoring.
这几乎就像你为过多的自我反思付出了代价。弗雷德，我想知道这是否与你之前告诉我的相矛盾，当我们谈到元认知的作用时，品味不仅仅是简单地享受某样东西，而是意识到你正在享受某样东西，注意到它，这个想法是否与这项研究中的想法相矛盾，即你越关注你正在享受的事情，你就越不享受它？非常好，尚卡尔。这是品味的悖论之一。
The irony is that in order to savour, you have to be aware of the positive feelings. You have to tell yourself, I like this, I'm feeling good, this is wonderful. The trouble is in the school or study, people stayed in that evaluative frame of mind. They kept asking themselves, how much am I enjoying it? Am I still enjoying it?
讽刺的是，为了品味，你必须意识到积极的感受。你必须告诉自己，我喜欢这个，我感觉很好，这太美妙了。问题在于在舒勒的研究中，人们停留在了那种评估性的心态中。他们不断问自己，我享受它有多少？我还在享受它吗？
Am I happy yet? Am I still happy? Maybe not. You can see that takes you away from the very positive stimulus that you started with. So the idea is to dance back and forth. It's to waltz, to tango with the positive feelings. You do need to be aware of them.
我快乐了吗？我还在快乐吗？也许没有。你可以看到这把你从你开始的那个非常积极的刺激中带走了。所以这个想法是来回跳舞。是华尔兹，是与积极的感受跳探戈。你确实需要意识到它们。
You need to name them, to wallow in them. Ah, here it is. Listen to the strings in this musical passage. Listen to the counterpoint from the brass section. They must have worked for hours on this. How many people are playing? How amazing humans are to have created these things and then lose yourself in the moment, let go of the evaluations and the judgments. And you can't spend too much time in either one of those reflective or absorption frames of mind. Savoring can bring us happiness, shield us from depression, and make us more resilient
你需要命名它们，沉溺于它们。啊，在这里。听听这段音乐片段中的弦乐。听听铜管乐部分的对位。他们一定为此工作了几个小时。有多少人在演奏？人类创造了这些东西是多么令人惊奇，然后迷失在当下，放下评估和判断。你不能在那些反思或吸收的心态中花太多时间。品味可以给我们带来快乐，保护我们免受抑郁，并使我们更有韧性
in the face of adversity. But a variety of hidden barriers keep us from doing it. One of the most important of those barriers is that we fail to see the many different shades of savoring that are available to all of us in daily life. That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Fred Bryan is a psychologist at Loyola University Chicago. He is the co-author with Joseph Vieroff of the book Savoring, a new model of positive experience. Fred, you say that there are many opportunities for savoring in everyday
面对逆境。但各种隐藏的障碍阻止我们这样做。这些障碍中最重要的一点是，我们未能看到在日常生活中对我们所有人可用的许多不同品味色调。这就是我们回来时要讲的。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。弗雷德·布莱恩特是芝加哥洛约拉大学的心理学家。他是与约瑟夫·维罗夫合著的《品味：积极体验的新模型》一书的合著者。弗雷德，你说在日常生活中有很多品味的机会
life that many of us overlook and becoming aware of all the many Types and shades of savoring maybe the first step to living a richer and more satisfying life When you were in the third grade you got an assignment to get some mushrooms from the forest And you had a chat with someone in your household who was a master at savoring tell me what happened oh Thank you so Sean Carver, reminding me of this cherished memory. That was a very early savoring adventure with my mother, Mary Lee. And the assignment was to go out into the forest, living in the hills of West Virginia, there were forests all around us and collect mushrooms. We were defined as many as we could mount them in some form, make a presentation and exhibit
生活，我们许多人忽视了这一点，意识到所有许多类型的品味色调可能是过上更丰富、更令人满意生活的第一步。当你上三年级时，你接到一个任务，从森林里弄些蘑菇，你和你家里的一位品味大师聊了聊，告诉我发生了什么。哦，谢谢你，尚卡尔，提醒我这个珍贵的回忆。那是我和我母亲玛丽·李的一次非常早期的品味冒险。任务是走进森林，住在西弗吉尼亚的山里，周围都是森林，收集蘑菇。我们被定义为尽可能多地找到它们，以某种形式安装它们，做一个展示和展览
out of them. The task was straight forward, but I wasn't sure even how to approach it. It just sounded like a drudgery and stress to me, So I mentioned it to my mom and it was a Saturday morning. She said, let's figure out how we'll do this. These things are waiting for us. They're hiding. Where do you think we'll find them? I said, I don't know.
把它们拿出来。任务很简单，但我甚至不知道该如何着手。对我来说，这听起来就像苦差事和压力，所以我向我妈妈提到了它，那是一个星期六的早晨。她说，让我们弄清楚我们将如何做这件事。这些东西在等着我们。它们在躲藏。你认为我们会在哪里找到它们？我说，我不知道。
Where might we go? I should have seen steered us to a creek that flowed up into the hills behind the end of the street. And I'd not spent a lot of time way back in there. So we decided she said, let's go up in there. What will we need to take with us? Well, I don't know. Well, we'll need something to carry them and what we want.
我们可能会去哪里？我本应该看到她引导我们去了一条流向街道尽头后面山上的小溪。我没有花太多时间在那后面。所以我们决定她说，让我们去那里。我们需要带什么去？嗯，我不知道。嗯，我们需要带东西去装它们，我们想要什么。
So, well, maybe a paper bag. Great idea. Let's take several because we don't know how many we'll need. We don't want to crush them. Maybe we'll find a lot more than we could imagine. Oh, and we want to keep track of where we find them, where are they hiding? And she had a small smile notebook with a pencil. Maybe we would take a snack with us. This started to sound fun. This sounded like we were going into some place unknown started to sound fun. It sounded like we were going to someplace unknown that we were exploring.
嗯，也许带个纸袋。好主意。我们多带几个，因为不知道会用到多少。我们不想把它们压坏。也许我们会发现比想象中多得多的蘑菇。哦，我们还得记录下在哪里找到它们的，它们都藏在哪儿？她带了一个小小的微笑笔记本和一支铅笔。也许我们还可以带点零食。这听起来开始变得有趣了。这听起来好像我们要去某个未知的地方，开始变得有趣了。这听起来好像我们要去某个未知的地方探险。
And I remember making our way there and the finding the first one under a fern. Way off the path where we'd been. And she came running over and I was thrilled to be able to show what I found. We made a few notes about it. We pulled it out of the ground and we smelled it. We were really drinking in the all of the experience. I couldn't wait to see the next one.
我记得我们一路走去，在蕨类植物下发现了第一个。离我们走过的小路很远。她跑了过来，我非常激动能展示我的发现。我们做了一些记录。我们把它从土里拔出来，闻了闻。我们真的沉浸在整个体验之中。我迫不及待地想看到下一个。
This must have gone on for, I don't know, an hour or two, finding all sorts of things, wondering how many hundreds and hundreds of mushrooms were there were surrounding us that we'd never known, never seen, trying to guess how old they were and She said, look how many we have. Can you believe it? Remember we had none and how much we'd look forward to what we'd find? Here we are. We're here now. Then she talked, oh, let's go home. What are we going to do? We get home Let's look forward to it and and then tonight we're going to look back on this. She showed me this mental time machine that Savory can involve.
这过程大概持续了一两个小时，我们发现了各种各样的东西，好奇在我们周围到底有多少成百上千个我们从未了解、从未见过的蘑菇，试着猜猜它们有多大年纪。她说，看我们有多少收获。你能相信吗？记得我们刚开始一个都没有，而且我们是多么期待会有什么发现吗？我们现在就在这儿。然后她说，哦，我们回家吧。我们要做什么呢？我们到家后，让我们期待一下，今晚我们要回顾这一切。她向我展示了这种“品味”所能带来的心理时间机器。
When one uses the mind in that way, the ability to travel back and forth in time, she was showing me how to do this, teaching me, how to go about doing this. All of these tricks ended up being one of my favorite things I ever did in grade school. You know, I love the idea of mental time travel because you call this both prospective and retrospective savoring. And in the little example you gave me about going mushroom hunting with your mom, there's ample evidence of both those things, right?
当一个人以这种方式运用思维，即在时间中来回穿梭的能力时，她是在向我展示如何做到这一点，教我如何去实践。所有这些技巧最终成了我在小学时最喜欢做的事情之一。你知道，我喜欢心理时间旅行这个概念，因为你称之为前瞻性和回顾性的“品味”。在你刚才举的和你妈妈一起去采蘑菇的例子中，有充分的证据表明这两者都存在，对吧？
So you're anticipating what you're going to find. You're trying to imagine how wonderful it's going to be, you're trying to think about where you will find these things, and then you find them, and then you celebrate when you find them, and then you look back at the end of the day, and you say, do I remember where I found them? And so in some ways, you're trying to extract every last ounce of joy juice, so to say, from the search for mushrooms.
所以你在期待即将发现的东西。你试着想象它会是多么美妙，你试着思考会在哪里找到这些东西，然后你找到了它们，当你找到时你庆祝一番，然后在一天结束时回顾，你说，我记得我在哪里找到它们的吗？所以从某种程度上说，你是在试图从寻找蘑菇的过程中，榨取最后一点“快乐果汁”。
That's it. of joy juice, so to say, from the search for mushrooms. That's it. She was able to find joy ahead of time, and then when we were in the moment, remind me, remind herself that some of the things we'd look forward to, building memories to be recalled later. We got home, we looked over the whole adventure from start to finish, remembered it, and shared it. Part of it was sharing it with her, magnified, the savoring, because she would point out to
就是这样。从寻找蘑菇的过程中榨取最后一点“快乐果汁”。就是这样。她能够提前找到快乐，然后在我们身处其中时，提醒我，也提醒她自己，我们所期待的一些事情，正在构建以后可以回忆的记忆。我们回到家，从头到尾回顾了整个冒险过程，记住了它，并分享了它。分享过程的一部分是与她分享，这放大了“品味”的快乐，因为她会向我指出
me things she found beautiful. I would also then be encouraged to find little things that I found pleasurable and fun. Things she did not see, and it was delight to see her laugh at what I discovered. I realized later on in my life that that was what drove my career studying savoring, 40 years of studying savoring. She certainly understood it, not from research, but from having learned it from her father and then passing it along to me. Notice that Fred's mother was not doing what Fred's brother did ahead of Christmas. His brother had built up anticipation of Christmas by imagining more presents, better presents, and picture perfect snowy weather.
她觉得美的东西。我也因此受到鼓励，去寻找我发现的那些微小而有趣的东西。那些她没看到的东西，看到她为我的发现而大笑，真是令人高兴。后来我意识到，正是这一点推动了我的职业生涯，让我研究“品味”，研究了40年。她当然理解这一点，不是通过研究，而是从她父亲那里学到，然后传给了我。注意，弗雷德的母亲并没有做弗雷德的兄弟在圣诞节前做的那种事。他的兄弟通过想象更多的礼物、更好的礼物和如画般的下雪天气，来建立对圣诞节的期待。
He then felt disappointed when reality felt short of his expectations. Fred's mother focused on enjoying the ordinary. It was just a school project to find some mushrooms. But by slowing down, Fred's mom showed him that there was wonder to be extracted from the ordinary. At every stage, she preferentially focused on the version of the story that would make them happiest. Before they went out, she asked Fred to imagine finding lots and lots of mushrooms.
当现实达不到他的期望时，他感到失望。弗雷德的母亲专注于享受平凡。这只是一个寻找蘑菇的学校作业。但通过放慢节奏，弗雷德的妈妈向他展示了平凡之中也可以提取出奇迹。在每一个阶段，她都有意地专注于那个能让他们最快乐的故事版本。在他们出发前，她让弗雷德想象找到许许多多的蘑菇。
After they had found a couple, she told him, remember how we thought we might find none? And after they got home, she helped Fred focus on the best parts of the day. In some ways, she was taking advantage of errors in the way the mind works, to combat the propensity of the mind to focus on the negative. Fred says research has backed up his mother's insight. There are some researchers, Mitchell and Thompson, very well-known in the happiness literature, studied vacations, European trips, bicycle trips, asking them to how good I thought it would be beforehand,
在他们找到几个之后，她告诉他，还记得我们以为可能一个都找不到吗？在他们回家后，她帮助弗雷德专注于这一天中最美好的部分。从某种程度上说，她是在利用思维运作方式中的偏差，来对抗思维倾向于关注负面事物的习性。弗雷德说，研究支持了他母亲的洞见。有一些研究人员，米切尔和汤普森，在幸福感文献中非常有名，他们研究了假期、欧洲旅行、自行车旅行，询问人们事先认为会有多好，
that prospection. And in the moment, they asked them to rate how they're feeling and describe the pleasures of the experience. And then afterwards, to look back, rating how good it was, what they found was, as you described, this tendency to look back on things and remember them as having been more pleasant than they were at the time. People are idealizing it. They term that rosy retro-spection.
那种前瞻。在体验过程中，他们要求人们评价自己的感受并描述体验的乐趣。事后，再回顾评价它有多好，他们发现正如你所描述的那样，人们有一种倾向，回顾往事时会觉得它们比当时实际情况更令人愉快。人们在理想化它。他们称之为“玫瑰色回顾”。
The same thing actually held true for the prospection. A thing before it occurs when you're imagining it, it seems much better than it actually was at the time. Much as my brother would idealize Christmas before it happened, they called that rosy prospection. It's just a human tendency. They analyze why that would happen. And they found that in the moment there are all sorts of distractions, there are things that are unpleasant. We don't encode those as memories afterwards. So when you look back, you don't remember that your knee was sore, or you don't remember that the weather was cold, the uncertainties,
同样的情况实际上也适用于前瞻。在事情发生之前，当你想象它时，它看起来比实际发生时要好得多。就像我兄弟在圣诞节发生前会理想化它一样，他们称之为“玫瑰色前瞻”。这只是一种人类的倾向。他们分析了为什么会发生这种情况。他们发现，在当下有各种各样的干扰，有一些不愉快的事情。事后我们不会把这些编码为记忆。所以当你回顾时，你不记得膝盖酸痛，也不记得天气寒冷，那些不确定性，
the little things that were unpleasant or fell short are sloughed off, leaving the gist of it, that we can polish, like the facets of a diamond. What we're doing is we're savoring the way it makes us feel to remember. It's a subtle distinction, and that's an important one. The savoring isn't just rekindling the exact feelings you had when you look back. It is relishing the way it feels to look back. Again, the savoring is always in the here and now. The feeling now when you look back, the feeling now when you look forward. You've noticed gender differences between men and women and their capacity to save our
那些不愉快或不尽如人意的小事都被抛弃了，留下了精华，我们可以像打磨钻石的切面一样去润色它。我们所做的是在“品味”回忆带给我们的感觉。这是一个微妙的区别，也是一个重要的区别。这种“品味”不仅仅是重温你回顾时所拥有的确切感受。它是享受回顾时的那种感觉。再次强调，“品味”总是在此时此地。回顾时的当下感受，展望时的当下感受。你注意到了男性和女性在“品味”事物能力上的性别差异，无论是在当下还是回顾时。你发现了什么，弗雷德？女性报告说她们更能充分地享受当下，从快乐时刻中获得她们认为能获得的所有快乐。相比之下，男性认为自己能做到的程度较低，她们似乎在感受发生时更能与自己的情感保持联系。男性有时更难识别积极的情绪，更难沉浸其中。
things, both in the present and when they're looking retrospectively. What do you find, Fred? Women report that they're more fully capable of enjoying the moment, of getting as much joy as they think they can from a happy moment. Compared to what men say, that men themselves are capable of, they seem to be more in touch with the feelings when they're happening. Men sometimes have a harder time identifying the positive feelings in the first place, and then lingering with them.
这只是一种文化差异，也许是因为主要的应对策略涉及压抑情感、否认和回避，而女性则不然。传统上，女性更善于表达她们的积极情绪。男性传统上把情感藏在心里，但代价是你错失了增强、强化这些情感的机会。女性倾向于花更多时间构建积极事物的记忆。所以她们在这些方面非常熟练，这可能与她们更丰富的内心生活和情感关联有关。通常男性在这方面比较困难。
It's just a cultural difference, maybe because they're dominant coping strategies, involve suppressing feelings and denying and avoiding more than women. Women traditionally, far more expressive of their positive feelings. Men have traditionally kept their feelings more to themselves, but the price is that you miss the opportunity to augment, to intensify, amplify those feelings. And women tend to spend more time building memories of a positive thing. So they're very skilled at these things, probably because of the richer inner life and association with feelings. Typically men have a harder time with that.
他们会谈论情感，但往往不被鼓励这样做，所以女性比男性做得多得多。所以你谈到了两种“品味”，一种是向外的，一种是更向内的。向外的“品味”你称之为“世界导向的品味”。你能给我一些例子说明它是如何运作的吗？世界导向的“品味”是指我们注意到外部令人愉悦的事物，比如我和妈妈一起采的蘑菇。
They'll talk about feelings that they're often not encouraged to do, so women do a lot more of that than men do. So you talk about two kinds of savoring, one that is outward focused, and one that is more inward focused. The outward focused savoring you call world focused savoring. Can you give me some examples of how this would work? The world-focused savoring is when we notice something outside us, that's pleasurable, like the mushrooms I hunted with my mom.
比如绝美的彩虹、大峡谷，或者某种电影里才有的神奇日落。换句话说，它来自外部，强烈地冲击我们，在内心创造出感觉。而“品味”的过程就是一种惊叹。“享受”是另一种世界导向的“品味”形式。来自外部，你感受着热水浴缸在身体上的触感，专注于这些事物如何影响我们。但那些外部世界的体验，世界导向的“品味”，与自我导向的“品味”非常不同，后者是我们“品味”
It is an exquisite rainbow or a grand canyon, some kind of magical sunset that's just out of a movie. In other words, it comes from the outside, it hits us hard to create feelings inside. And the savoring process is one of marveling. Luxureating is another form of savoring that's outward-focused. Coming from the outside, you're feeling the warm hot tub on one's body, focusing on the ways those things affect us. But those outer world experiences, world-focused saving, very different from self-focused savoring, where we're savoring the
内心的感受，而不是外部的刺激。比如成就感，完成了一项我们努力工作的任务，或者对我们意义重大的事情。我们可能会享受辛苦一天或一次很棒的锻炼后的疲劳感。实际上，大多数“品味”体验是两者的结合。即使是世界导向的“品味”体验，也必须通过感受进入我们内心，我们必须专注于这些感受。所以幸福不在事物中，而在我们心中。
feelings inside us as opposed to the stimulus outside us. Something like pride and accomplishment, than having finished a task that we've worked hard on or something that means a lot to us. We might relish a feeling of fatigue after a hard day's labor or a great workout. In reality, most savoring experiences are blends of the two. Even a world-focused savoring experience has to get in us with the feelings, and we have to focus on those feelings. So happiness is not in things, it's in us.
是这些事物在我们内心创造的感觉。那是“品味”的燃料。那是“品味”的燃料。你谈到感恩是“品味”的引擎之一。感恩与“品味”有什么关系？感恩是识别来自外部馈赠者的礼物的一种能力。恩人可以是朋友。可以是陌生人。可以是陌生人，可以是神灵，
It's the feelings that these things create inside us. That's the fuel for the savoring. It's the fuel for the savoring. You talk about gratitude as being one of the engines for savoring. What does gratitude have to do with savoring? Gratitude is the ability to pinpoint a gift from an external gift giver. The benefactor could be a friend. It could be a stranger. It could be a stranger, it could be a deity,
可以是爱人。但这是一种外部事物，它祝福了我们，给了我们积极的东西，除非这些领悟冲击到我们，并且我们在认知上对此进行反思，否则就没有感恩。你把礼物递给一个很小的孩子，家长说，你该说什么？孩子说，这真好。你说，不，不，不，你要说谢谢。孩子还没有真正发展出识别这是需要感恩之物的能力。
it could be a loved one. But this is something outside us, which is blessed us, given us something positive, unless those realizations hit us, and we reflect on that cognitively, there is no gratitude. You hand a very young child a gift and the parent says, what do you say to their child? And child says, this is really good. You say, no, no, no, you don't say, say thank you. The child hasn't really developed the capacity to recognize that this is something for which to give thanks.
这是随着时间推移学到的。所以你和其他人认为，与非常强烈的“品味”体验相比，拥有许多“品味”体验更为重要。为什么会这样呢，弗雷德？强度固然好，但随着时间推移会消退。就好像大脑中有一个部分，
It's something learned over time. So you and others have argued that it's more important to have many experiences of savoring as compared to very intense experiences of savoring. Why would this be the case, Fred? The intensity is fine and good, but that will wear off over time. It's almost as if there's a part of the mind,
一个隐藏的部分在记分。大脑中有一个隐藏的部分在记分。并且以某种方式有一个统计表，我们有很多积极的体验。它们会积累。它们会建立。它们会积聚。这是伊利诺伊大学的埃德·迪纳（Ed Diener）的一项发现，他是幸福感研究的开拓者。这看起来可能违反直觉，但数据说明了一切。
a hidden part that keeps score. And there's a part of the mind, a hidden part, that keeps score. And there's a tally sheet in some fashion that we haven't many positive experiences. They accrue. They build. They accumulate. This was a finding by Ed Deener, University of Illinois, a ground breaker in the research on well-being and happiness. It may seem counterintuitive, but the data speak.
再次强调，生活中的小事，知道它们似乎比一次大型庆祝活动更重要，是非常令人鼓舞的。就好像你可以强烈地“品味”一次盛大的庆祝活动，然后这一年就完事了。它不是那样运作的。你不能像骆驼那样一次摄入很多并保持住。我们随时间而褪色。
Again, the small things, the little things in life, it's very encouraging to know that they are the ones that seem to count more than one big celebration could, as if you could savor a huge celebration intensely and you're done for the year. It doesn't work that way. You cannot, like, a camel take a lot of it and hold onto it. We fade over time.
我们需要被补充，重新供应。所以你的合著者乔·维罗思（Joe Veroff）有一个策略，从阅读成年子女的信件中获取最大的快乐。在许多方面，他的策略触及了我们过去几分钟讨论的一些主题。你能为我描绘一下他做了什么吗？乔和我都在写这本书时
We need to be replenished, resupply it. So your co-author, Joe Verov, had a strategy to extract the most pleasure from reading letters from his grown children. And in many ways, his strategy speaks to some of the themes we've been discussing in the last few minutes. Can you paint me a picture of what he did? Joe and I both in writing this book
写下了我们最喜欢的“品味”体验。多年来，他和他的孩子们习惯写他们所谓的“连锁信”。他通常会发起。他会给其中一个孩子写信。孩子们随后会写他们自己的信。他通常会发起。他会给其中一个孩子写信，孩子们随后会写他们自己的信。他会把他的信和他们的信一起装好，寄给另一个兄弟姐妹。他有五个孩子。所以这需要一段时间。第二个孩子会收到乔最初的信和第二个兄弟姐妹的
wrote down our favorite kinds of savoring experiences. And for many years, he and his children used to write what they called a chain letter. He would often start it. He would write a letter to one of his kids. And the kids then would be writing their own letter. He would often start it. He would write a letter to one of his kids, and the kids then would be writing their own letter. He would enclose his letter with their own and send the letter to another sibling. He had five children. And so this would take a period of time. The second child would have Joe's original letter and the second siblings
信，然后在他们自己的时间写一封信。这可以是任何想到的事情。他们的想法、见解、恐惧、梦想，发生在他们身上的事情。这是一种让他们分享的方式，但跨越了很长一段时间。直到最后，最后一封信回到他手中，他会收到五封信，加上他最初的信。这些连锁信一年大约会传两三次。
letter, and then in their own time write a letter. This would just be anything that came to mind. Their thoughts, their insights, their fears, their dreams, things that were happening to them. There's a way for them to share, but across a long period of time. Until finally, the last letter would come back to him, and he would get five letters in addition to his original letter. These chain letters came around about two or three times a year.
最后，把它们放在一起读，乔说，他只是喜欢在它们到来时阅读。他并不总是立刻读。他会找一个安静的时刻，非常缓慢且从容地阅读每一封信。这是一种共同“品味”生活的美丽而有创意的方式。他说，当他读信时，他能感觉到家人聚集在他周围的房间里。这比电话或电子邮件持久得多。电子邮件会被掩埋。这是他保留并珍视的东西。我怀疑他把它传给了他的孩子们。
And finally, reading them all together, Joe said, was he just loved reading them when they came. He didn't always read them instantly. He would find a quiet moment where he could read each one very slowly and deliberately. It's a beautifully creative way of savoring life together. He could feel, he said, his family gathered in the room around him as he read the letter. It's so much more lasting than a phone call or an email. The emails get buried. This was something he held onto and cherished. I suspect he passed it along to his children.
可能他在去世后，孩子们发现了这些信。不过，这是一个绝妙的主意，能够看到当跨越时间观察时，整体的总和要大得多。在我们关于“品味”的迷你系列第二部分，即下一集中，我们将深入探讨更多从生活中提取最大快乐的技巧。我可以给你举一些它将包含的内容的例子，但真的，为什么你不花一分钟想象一下等待着你的快乐呢？
Probably they found the letters after he died. It's a wonderful idea, though, to be able to see the sum of the parts is so much bigger when seen across time like this. In the second part of our mini-series on savoring, coming up in our next episode, we dive into more techniques to extract the greatest pleasure from life. I could give you some examples of what it will contain, but really, why don't you take a minute and imagine the pleasures that await you.
弗雷德·布莱恩特（Fred Bryant）是芝加哥洛约拉大学的心理学家。他与约瑟夫·维罗思（Joseph Veroff）合著了《品味：积极体验的新模型》（Savoring: A New Model of Positive Experience）一书。弗雷德，感谢你今天加入“隐藏的大脑”（Hidden Brain）。谢谢你，桑卡尔。这是我的荣幸。“隐藏的大脑”由“隐藏的大脑媒体”（Hidden Brain Media）制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲-保罗（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐藏的大脑”的执行编辑。
Fred Bryant is a psychologist at Loyola University Chicago. He is the author with Joseph Veroth of the book Savaring, a new model of positive experience. Fred, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, son Carrot. It's pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
我们本周的无名英雄是安妮·斯旺森（Annie Swanson）。安妮是HWP保险公司的客户经理，该公司帮助我们处理员工的健康保险。我们最近需要向联邦政府发送一些医疗保健数据，而提交这些数据的过程令人困惑且有些艰巨。幸运的是，安妮加入了一个电话会议，并分享了一些故障排除文档，帮助我们快速完成了员工待办事项清单。谢谢你，安妮，感谢你的支持，让我们能够回到我们喜欢做的工作中，
Our unsung hero this week is Annie Swanson. Annie is an account manager at HWP Insurance, a company that helps us with health insurance for our staff. We recently needed to send some healthcare data to the federal government, and the process for submitting that data was confusing and a bit daunting. Luckily for us, Annie hopped on a call and shared some troubleshooting documents that helped us to quickly check the staff off our two-do list. Thank you, Annie, for your support, so we could get back to doing the work we like to do,
制作更多“隐藏的大脑”剧集。如果你正在享受，或者说正在“品味”我们的YouTube系列，我们很乐意让你与两三位你认为会喜欢它们的人分享这些剧集。口碑推荐在向新听众介绍“隐藏的大脑”方面起着巨大的作用。我是桑卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。很快再见。
making more episodes of Hidden Brain. If you're enjoying, or perhaps savoring our YouTube.os series, we'd love for you to share these episodes with two or three people who you think would enjoy them. Word of mouth recommendations make a huge difference in introducing new listeners to Hidden Brain? I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon.
你 本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
目前还没有关于本集的评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。